of the passing of her majesty queen  elizabeth ii  she was our queen  for almost half of canada's existence  and she had an obvious  deep  and abiding love and affection for  canadians  she served us all with strength  and wisdom  for 70 years  as we grew into the diverse  optimistic  responsible  ambitious and extraordinary country we  are today  as her  twelfth  canadian prime minister i'm having  trouble believing  that my last sit down with her  was my last  i will so miss those chats  she was  thoughtful  wise  curious  helpful  funny  and so much more  in  a complicated world  her steady grace  and resolve  brought comfort and strength to us all  canada  is in mourning  she was one of my favorite people in the  world  and i will miss her so  sit awaken  that's the  canadian prime minister justin trudeau  remembering queen elizabeth